le camp de gebalia dans la bande de Gaza
il faut venir ici pour comprendre l'une
des raisons du soulèvement de ces
derniers jours la
surpopulation la bande de Gaza enclaave
palestinienne coincée entre la
Méditerranée Israël et
l'Égypte une véritable poudrière au cœur
du Proche Orient mais comment en est-on
arrivé
là après la création d'Israël des
centaines de milliers de Palestiniens
prennent la fuite ou sont chassés
nous appelons tous les Juifs de la
Diaspora à se joindre à nous et à nous
prêter mains forte pour faire que la
rédemption d'Israël soit assumée jusqu'à
la fin des siècles 170000 palestinien
trouve refuge dans les camps de la bande
de Gaza sous contrôle
égyptien juin 1967 c'est la guerre des 6
jours Israël s'empare de ce
[Musique]
territoire
[Applaudissements]
les conditions de vie se dégradent avec
les années et en 1987 la jeunesse
Gazaoui se soulève c'est la première
Intifada pierre contre fusil rapport de
force inégale d'une agitation devenue
quotidienne dans les territoires occupés
par Israël depuis
1967 hier à Naplouse aujourd'hui à Gaza
les forces de l'ordre israélienne ont
tiré des grenades lacrimogènes mais
aussi des balles sur les
bil et des dizaines de blessés depuis 3
mois les soldats israéliens qui ont
perdu de hommes ont tué 16 palestiniens
au cours d'opération
Antime la situation est incontrôlable
dans ces territoires occup où les jeunes
sont encore plus radicalement hos à la
tutelle de téav que les un conflit qui
conduira des négociations de paix en
1993 un accord est signé entre israélien
et
palestinien
Shalom salam une image impensable il y a
encore quelques semaines seulement la
poignée de main entre les deux ennemis
irréductibles d'hier le Premier ministre
israélien Isac Rabin et le président de
l'OLP Yasser Arafat l'administration du
territoire est confiée à l'Autorité
palestinienne un gouvernement dirigé par
Yasser Arafat le dirigeant de l'OLP
organisation de libération de la
Palestine est accueilli en héros à Gaza
un baiser d'amour sur le sol brûlant de
la bande de Gaza il était 14h13 à cet
instant précis le rêve pour lui devient
réalité c'est Rafa le point de passage
entre l'Égypte Israël et la bande de
Gaza Arafat est passé sans avoir été
contrôlé par les soldats israéliens
l'honneur est je veux vous rappeler dit
Arafat que nous avons devant nous une
grande mission celle de construire la
patrie nos institutions reconstruire
celle détruite par l'occupation
israélienne mais le Hamas bras armé des
Frères musulmans ne veut pas cette paix
et provoque une vague d'attent à suicide
organisé depuis
Gaza en 2006 le Hamas remporte les
élections législatives palestiniennes
c'est une entrée symbolique celle d'un
militant du Hamas au Parlement
palestinien un parlement désormais aux
couleurs du parti islamiste le ramas a
gagné il prendra bientôt officiellement
possession des lieux ce n'est pas
seulement une victoire du Hamas c'est
aussi une victoire de la
as pour faires nécessaires se
débarrasser de la corruption s suivent
de violents affrontements entre le fata
parti nationaliste palestinien et le
Hamas depuis 5
jours les affrontements
interpalestiniens entre le Hamas et le
fata se sont
intensifiés au moins 78 morts depuis
samedi et de nombreux blessés plusieurs
positions stratégiques et des postes de
sécurité sont tombés aux mains du Ham
depuis 2007 la bande de Gaza est soumise
à un blocus israélo-égyptien qui
entraîne des pénuries et des coupures
d'électricité nous allons mourir de faim
la situation à Gaza était déjà mauvaise
et nous n'avons même plus une seule
tomate à manger ni moi ni les
autres à la frontière Israël a bloqué ce
matin ce convoi de 30 camions qui
devaient acheminer l'aide alimentaire un
blocus total décidé en représail au tir
de roquette palestinien qui ont repris
sur les
la situation à Gaza est catastrophique
car 750000 réfug dépend de l'aide
alimentaire
deu au centre de distribution ses
habitants sont venus se ravitailler une
dernière fois aujourd'hui la situation
devient tendue une situation dénoncé par
l'onuocos à band gaz est contuc
intenable et
immor des civils innocents Israël doit
le lever
immédiatement régulièrement des
affrontements éclatent entre Israël et
la bande de Gaza faisant toujours plus
de victimes des deux côtés de la
frontière